i did the toad right in there and once i
did the told my whole life change i woke
up boom straight
never had the desire to drink i just
wanted to be um the best of my the
highest to the height of my
possibilities right right i mean um five
muo has been a part of my journey you
know big dose psilocybin uh really
helped me recover uh my quality of life
my brain
i'm gonna do it yeah today
that's great that's great with a shaman
with somebody uh you know proper dosage
set setting yeah yeah
i go up to like a
250. okay
okay when do you know that you that you
need it like do you get called to it or
or do you yeah
yeah
because when i did it it was um it was a
stack therapy like a full day
and i was i was really there to to save
my life i was in a similar position that
you were right with everything kind of
my relationships were i was i was
depressed i was suicidal and um and
these these medicines really helped
bring me out of it um and then you you
dive into the science about it how they
they connect different hemispheres of
the brain that were once shut down
i mean um
you know it's it's it's pretty
remarkable this is pretty remarkable
daniel why is it when i do mushrooms or
something
um the [ __ ] trees and plants start
talking me and they're moving and [ __ ]
they happen to you too
yeah i i high at high dose yeah for sure
there's hallucinations
but that's the key is is is like uh
tolerance and then and then you build up
the more that you take this medicine if
you don't take a break
you you really don't want to tolerance
start off slow yeah yeah when you go
back to it yeah yeah he's being like my
stuff slow slow enough so let's try this
28 back to your five yeah right cheese
geez i like to think i like to think
yeah i don't know if i find my way back
to successful
um
yeah yeah yeah
man i mean it does
like what i'm interested in too is you
know a lot of people are doing high dose
to for depression or or for anxiety or
or to come back i think i think i think
what's that
what's that dosa again they do i forgot
um
like a micro dose with no [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah they do that microdose that that
meddles a lot of guys out for sure on a
daily basis yeah right and then too much
might get you weird but that's a little
micro
keep you level uh-huh for sure i mean it
hits it hits all the right um happy
chemicals in the brain right serotonin
yeah yeah and over a longer period of
time like it does show and it keeps you
sharp real sharp
but like that's what i'm interested in
amplify performance yeah it amplifies it
and i think what's crazy about what
we've learned is amplified
it can amplify your it's like
when you're
daniel always says but it sharpens
certain aspects that you're already
sharp and it makes you even multiplies
it right
which could be
good or bad yeah depending on the person
and depending on the strain the genetics
of the strain depending on why you're
using it that's the biggest that's the
biggest thing is is intention i always
have an intention any time that i micro
dose or any time that i go into a
ceremony it's for a very specific reason
um and then when i come out or during
that ceremony i always get what i need
because psilocybin specifically
exasperates or or what's at the
forefront of our mind right so it's so
funny you said that
everything that i um
i forgot i forgot what they called
manifest
came true mm-hmm
right and it's so weird and i mean it
just came true right right yeah i mean
it's uh you know first um
this um we were banked up almost almost
and then you got one guy um one of our
partners he got stuck for like 15
million he lost right and this i said
this is some white [ __ ] right check this
out
take that loss we're going to talk to
the other investors and get their money
anyway we're going to put more money
here and say listen man this is some
[ __ ] [ __ ] they'll be getting in on
this side of the corner you couldn't
come out your house
you know what i mean yeah [ __ ]
yeah
the 15 minutes
i think i think though back to the
stories like tyson ranch has so much
potential right you know where it's
where it's going and your brand like
people want to recap i love that word
recap oh it's a beautiful word recap the
thing is about what you guys are doing
also like from an education standpoint
growing up i think everyone growing up
were told drugs drugs which was just one
big name not a specific drug
i'm from new york right yeah um
but wherever you were from just drugs
were anti-productivity yeah
if you were an athlete forget it it
would be the opposite thing that you
would ever consider doing whether it was
cigarettes alcohol weed or anything
harder lazy stoners right yeah ladies
and gentlemen i'll be honest before i
started in cannabis that was my you know
thought yeah you have to get educated
yeah i wasn't educated so you have work
to do clearly meaning
the fact that you guys are proponents
for education and the added value
benefits that aren't about just partying
getting [ __ ] up and then like passing
out throwing yeah so enticing ranch
you're gonna eventually go out well and
put a university up there cannabis
university and educate the people how
they just grow how you mix green you
know it's gonna be really fun
educational perspectives i mean the war
on drugs is just
absolute failure and when you think
about schedule one
drugs marijuana
so and then psilocybin magic mushrooms
right high abuse liability which we know
isn't true
and no medicinal value there are medical
marijuana programs all over the united
states but this they are still both
federally
illegal right just because of the
scheduling if we can continue to educate
and we can continue to push forward
awareness on what these medicines can do
the descheduling the reason i'm very
passionate about decrement movements
is to get these medicines descheduled so
then you can bring them into the context
of making them a medicine without the
red tape so it won't take me five to
seven years with we sauna to research
the active ingredient of psilocybin
for
depression or traumatic brain injury
related anxiety so i mean we have a
you know what you're doing with your
following and your platform and tyson
ranch is is is extremely important and
what you're doing for psychedelics as
well and i'm just grateful that
you know i don't know how we met we were
talking about this the other day you
were sitting here
we worked out of my we worked out of my
office we called the war room a lot of
good things happened there yeah um and i
was like you know we need to help the
stigma type we were thinking about we
just i have filo we were starting wesana
he came you reached out to me on
linkedin
and uh
and i'm like we got to get mike on
working with us because mike has a great
footprint i'm talking with mushrooms
then we had brian spears
working at filo reached out to the zine
got us in
touch with mike and that's how we're
here
it's all crazy how cannabis psilocybin
they all are intertwined yeah you see
all the same people involved because
very similar missions like you said
right at the same time you're fighting
the same battle right
destigmatizing something that i learned
that like athletes like you guys you
know you gotta you're at a sporting
event you're watching daniel carcillo
fight or mike fighting heavyweight no
one knows about the damage that you guys
deal with after
i think what's what we hope to see too
is
athletic organizations right allowing
people to utilize same thing treatments
you guys have so i think the government
is so afraid of this medicine
but marijuana sales are smashing alcohol
sales in illinois like once they start
what talks right is tax money money yeah
right so like that's why you're seeing
the yeah acceptance right i think you
saw that co i mean i you saw with kovitz
our business blew up when it became an
essential right right i can't go to
catch and get some sushi with my friends
but i can go to the retail dispensary
and buy weed right right so it change it
changed uh it changed the game yeah mark
for your question for you though with
eventually where it goes with like
lounges you know canvas lounges
eventually will come out more and more
like would you think anything would ever
happen with you with what you're doing
would you ever have lounges in the
restaurant or in the back
we have our own little lounge as well
yeah
no but um
when it becomes a actual cannabis lounge
with food and beverage i don't know that
i would do
catch with that yeah but you know like
being in the culinary business
um and we i kind of talked to your team
about that idea in general like what
would really go well with it like is it
sushi or is it like the greatest italian
you know pizza and
and like easy food to have that you
would desire maybe
but just like a dumbed-down version of
like a sophisticated restaurant well
it's like wine you look at cannabis like
wine you can correlate uh strains with
food
yeah but you would have to really do a
pairing it wouldn't just be like throw
catch on it no no no
in general you know but i think that
look food and beverage goes with
everything every activity we do revolves
around that so
certainly
you know as things get more creative and
and and
entrepreneurs start entering those
markets because of legality you will see
probably a tremendous amount of pairing
and yeah high middle and low you know
consumer you know pricing or whatever
it's going to be yeah it's going to be
it's going to be interesting in the next
two years you know if you're wearing
tyson ranch we had ideas to make a
little you know town there pretty much
and um
i was always wanting to um because i was
going to be a guest at the carnival in
rio yeah i would say on some nice
because there's a thousand acres up
there we could it would be like cuba
back in the 50s and 40s showgirls
movies just labyrinth um
luxury houses and stuff
and i and i i think that was going to be
a winner mm-hmm and he looked right off
he revealed um
i'm looking at the freeway right here so
easy to get here it's come up nice
and it's closer than
cello coach elliott yeah yeah
there's you're you're at really like
this pinnacle moment in time in an
industry like you can call it you know
the way prohibition ended and
the amount of innovation that came out
of that revolving around legal alcohol
selling
you're in the same kind of
kind of moment now where
even the conversation the fact that
you're having conversations at regular
dinner tables all across the country
about marijuana being legal and then
getting into businesses and you've got
young entrepreneurs all over the place
which stimulates no different than tech
amazing amounts of ideas and creativity
and you know
amusement park space around who knows
but i'm saying it's there's there's
really no end you're at the very
beginning of it you're at the forefront
of like this huge industry that we
already know has a giant demand well
it's interesting when we were when we
were filo technology company we came
from mainstream and try to hire people
people like they'd be interviewing for
the job they'd be like oh is this good
for my resume i'm like you're not right
fit for this yeah we started to bring in
you know
top talent from all that like you said
from the mainstream world and people
just want a new challenge yeah and it's
it's again it's it's like fun to learn
something and educate yourself right and
so then be at the forefront of like
influence how people actually like smoke
and how people are going to you know
take these everything i don't even like
calling them drugs but like take these
medicines you know it's uh it's pretty
in olympics in 1924
the bike riders
rode the bike they was passing
cigarettes to one another
and they were right oh yeah right before
they thought it was bad for them doctors
were smoking in commercials talking
about how healthy it is
it's it's you know it's an exciting time
for a lot of different things but
especially in the in the cannabis and
controlled substance space i think it's
going to be
you know you've got pop culture getting
involved you've got television shows
creating shows whether it's like this is
the beginning stage of the anti-aging
program yeah
what's your opinion on nad you know what
that is nad mm-hmm
yeah i tried doing that with uh
when i got coveted it's i don't know
they say it manipulates your cells and
it it's the anti-aging yeah
it
but it's supposed to slow your aging
process and even reverse the aging of
your cells
they say mushrooms does
he said that too
younger what doesn't mushrooms do that's
the danger
he said from
from a picture when you came out of the
nhl to where you are today yeah the
before and afters so one thing that you
see after big dose i don't know if you
notice it but um uh
you look
younger because of the potent
anti-inflammatory anti-oxidant benefits
of mushroom post-hallucination post okay
yeah post-serum not seeing yourself
no no no the first day
not so good
second day third day
um
what mushrooms do for like the gi tract
in your stomach because 90 of our
serotonin receptors aren't up here 90 of
them are in the gut that's why they say
the gut brain axis is so important uh
and such a strong connection so when you
think of it that way and and you
understand psilocybin and what how it
like it is a lock and key for serotonin
and that's why
sometimes you like get a little of the
energy stomach or cranks you here yeah
yeah yeah yeah craziest feeling ever but
i mean this is natural so like it's very
different than nad
this is
from spiritual
right now correct yeah and we can you
could get really spiritual about it but
these mushrooms have been around
yeah for millions and millions and
millions of years it's called a
technology because native americans have
used it for so if you
use it like very intentionally
um you can get these amazing benefits i
don't like
anti-aging maybe but it's just it makes
people i've sat with over 80 people now
the last two and a half years and and
led people through it it just makes you
[Music]
look younger
i think it's because of the way that it
makes you feel
[Music]